next question today hey David what would
happen if a Republican primary Donald
Trump in 2020 the answer is it would
depend on what's going on with Trump at
the time last week we talked about how
there are now rumblings in DC from some
Republicans who are saying if what
Muller comes out with is truly damaging
to Trump in a way that even they believe
it which you know don't hold your breath
for that that they may abandon Donald
Trump when it comes to 2020 so if indeed
the Republican Party at large turns on
Trump in the way some Republicans claim
to be privately considering then Trump
is in trouble and then it would be sort
of natural and obvious that there would
be a primary challenger if the
Republican Party remains mostly behind
Trump then whoever primaries Trump just
isn't going to have a shot they could
however end up hurting Trump enough that
it helps the Democrat which would be
great okay if you have a strong primary
challenger who is not unanimously backed
by the Republican Party or who at least
is splitting the Republican Party they
may do well enough in the Republican
primary to lose but to then run as
third-party candidates in the general
election and hand the victory to a
Democrat which would be absolutely
fantastic historically understand how
relatively rare this is the last time
that Republicans had I guess what I
would say a serious challenger to the
incumbent president running for
re-election was in 76 Gerald Ford was in
sort of rough shape politically he had
pardoned Nixon still had some of the
after-effects of Vietnam to contend with
Reagan gave them a pretty good challenge
the last time we had sort of subsequent
to that I mean maybe 92
where Pat Buchanan was in the running
although you know to say that that was a
really strong challenge I don't know
successful challenge you really have not
seen successful challenges within the
incumbents party on re-election years so
in short without the entire Republican
Party turning on Trump and remember most
Republican voters still support Trump
overwhelmingly I don't know at this
point if it's 80 85 % it's
a very very high number the best that a
Republican primary challenger could
really hope to do is to weaken Trump
which could help the Democratic
challenger ultimately win so I support
it and no matter what Republicans are
thinking about Donald Trump in 2020 I
hope that there is a primary challenge
and the stronger the Challenger the
better quite frankly